where were you when september 11th
happened uh i was
stationed at uh team five still and i
was living in the archstone apartments
right by the ikea
in mission valley watch the second one
go in live
yeah i remember it uh was living with a
buddy
and uh my wife we'd been married for
six months and watched the second one go
in live
and then you knew immediately did you
know what did you think were you
thinking on the first one because i
wasn't
the first one i didn't see the first one
going live i turned it on just in time
to see the second one
but i think it caught most people like
the first one they're like oh well that
pilot's probably in trouble
yeah it can be a lawsuit on that one and
then the second one there was no doubt
whatsoever and i didn't know i mean
looking back
i didn't have the mental capacity to
understand the difference that it would
have in my life
but i knew that something was going to
be different i mean i think i realized
that we were passing from the conceptual
phase
to the practical phase of what we had
trained to do for a really long period
of time
you know who did know that so the deet
the officer did so i was going to
college at the time
and i called the officer detailer who
was a friend of mine who i knew who i'd
worked for
who is an outstanding guy and i called
him up and i was like hey sir
i'm in college get me out of college
i'll finish online
i'll do something just get me out of
here send me to a team immediately
please
yeah please and he and he says to me
jocko don't worry this war is going to
last a long long time
and of course i didn't believe him yeah
but damn was he right he he was but i
mean i can only imagine being in your
shoes i would have been like i don't
really care
this is what my calling in life is to be
i don't i don't care if i'm in line to
get the nobel prize for something like
we'll just put that on the shelf
and i'll come back and get it nobel what
yeah like there's a war going on
and so you get done with that and then
shortly thereafter you ship out to the
east coast right yep go out to the east
coast
and uh did the vast majority of my
combat deployments out there
uh and wow i mean
what an eye-opening experience you know
it from like i said going from
conceptual shooting at paper targets and
training heart in realistic to
to being on a two-way range for the
first time i mean
uh the the first target i ever was on
uh i think my helicopter had 27 rounds
in it and the door gunner got shot in
the face
right in front of me and i'm in mop
level four
yeah for those either don't know what
that is that's the
that's the chemical biological and
radiate radiological
suit protection that you wear and
highest
you're wearing your mask you're wearing
everything
so it's it's a horrible uncomfortable
miserable thing to do and we had a
four hour 47 flight on the way to the
objective and 30 minutes out we
got all of our stuff on to include our
gas masks and the blowers they always
say if you had the blowers that does
make it a lot nicer well
unless you put your weapon strap over
the hose
[Laughter]
well i could go on for days about
mistakes i've made in my life uh so yeah
i would skip breathing and occasionally
the glass would touch my eyeball
because i couldn't breathe but
i mean this is my first real target ever
and it's
uh we're hitting the number one chem bio
target in iraq uh
right after the war kicked off and i was
on the third 47 that came in and they
blew the power grid
uh by an a10 strike uh before we landed
and then they landed the helicopters in
between
the fireball and the city so we were
back lit so each subsequent helicopter
that came in
uh took more rounds and by the time ours
came in they started taking rounds at
about a minute out
i didn't know what they were i'm just
sitting there looking through straws
you know through my gas mask through my
night vision goggles
suffocating myself because my weapon
strap is over the hose it's supposed to
be giving me the air
uh and you know there was some sparks
nobody nobody heard on the bird not a
single one of our guys shot
and then right before we touched down
the door gunner just falls over
and then you know the top of his head
kind of came off and
tied my you know tie my jacket around
his head and it just
took off and away we went on our first
combat operation but the whole thing was
just surreal
and that that leap i didn't realize how
surreal it was until the next morning
when i woke up and i was like
man i hope this is survivable
because that was just one of many in the
target deck and it continued for
months and then years and you know two
decades
decades yeah and it was and it took me a
little bit of time to get up and running
to be
to be comfortable in that environment
but i
i developed a level of comfort in that
environment and if i'm being totally
honest i mean
i loved it i
loved it it was i mean i i understand
that it's high consequence and
it's high risk and that there's there's
matters of life and death and decisions
that are being made but that's where i
want to be
i mean it that i was like yes this is
what i came to do
to fight for the values that i believe
in and to fight for people who can't
fight for themselves
and uh it was awesome loved it
it's interesting how you talk about that
um transition from
like from training which is what we all
lived there's very few people that this
is another thing that
it's hard for people to understand about
especially about the early days of the
sea well for us the early days the seal
teams is
there was so few people that actually
had combat experience
and that went all the way up to the
leadership a lot of leadership had no
combat experience
and so for us all of a sudden in a very
quick learning curve
you know you spend two weeks on
deployment you had more combat
experience than
you know than anybody else in the seal
teams at that time you know other than
the guys that were deployed right before
you but you had
that's how quick the learning curve was
and things were changing
i mean look at what we trained i mean we
were doing otb and exhaustion drager
dives and i'm doing river and stream
crossing and island
well i'm not kidding before my first
deployment to iraq i took
my seal platoon we went on board of an
amphibious landing ship
in san diego and went and no kidding did
lead line and slate beach reconnaissance
at camp pendleton that was that was
less than it might have been a month and
a half before deploying to iraq
to do operations that's how that's
that's that's the lag time in the big
bureaucratic machine in the military hey
you know we got this big uh fleet
exercise you guys can go participate in
one of one of our one of my guys in that
platoon
i come down and go hey break out your
lead line and say
so again for those of you that don't
know there's the a very prehistoric
type operation that was an excellent
descriptor
yeah it came from world war ii
it came after the battle of tarou at the
battle of tarawa the marines went in
and as they went into the beaches in
their landing craft they hit reef
and the the they opened the gates of the
of the
uh landing craft the marines got out and
unfortunately the reef
ended and so these guys these marines
went out and they went into you know 10
15 feet of water instead of two feet of
water and many many marines
heavy gear that was not buoyant it was
not designed for
swimming it was it was meant for beach
landing not for a swim
and anyways that was kind of one of the
precursors to the udts and
and what so what our our predecessors
used to do is go in
with a lead line which is a piece of
string with a lead on the bottom of it
and it's got little uh marks on it
called buntings little marks on it that
tell you how
deep it is and you go in as a big team
and you drop these lead lines and you
figure out how deep you and your slate
is a piece of plexiglas that's been
sanded down and you write with a pencil
on it how deep it was in this particular
location
it's like trying to do calculus with an
abacus basically
so so we are you know like
less than two months from deploying to
iraq for the first time none of us had
ever been in combat but
not one single person zero not one
single person in my seal platoon had
ever been in combat before
including our tasking commander no one
and so we say
oh you know what we need to do right now
is we're going to do
a hydrographic reconnaissance that's
what it's called the line of slave but
one of the guys might do what you what
do you do what are you talking about
and i go bro we're just going to do it
and it was like
you've got to be kidding me what is
wrong with us but so that learning curve
was fast but then but i also to to kind
of emphasize what you're saying
and i look at it when you said you know
your first like platoon you know like 20
and then your second platoon you know
for me because i have four kids
it's very similar to what you learn with
kids yes your first kid you're like oh
wait what
ha you don't know how to do anything
everything is hard you know you're
worried about everything
your second kid you're like i'm pretty
pretty much gonna do it your third kid
you're like okay you know i
i think we're comfortable your fourth
could be like i got this whatever
you're like hey first kid go take care
of your sibling exactly which is
which is really which is really exactly
what you do in the teams you're like hey
you know you know one cruise wonder go
show that new guy what's up because you
don't have to do it anymore
and you want them to learn the
experience but that's the same thing
with
the combat operations that you do and
over
you know a period of a couple weeks all
sudden you go from being you know i'll
give you another good example
from my perspective my first deployment
to iraq
when every operation we would go on like
the first
like let's call it five or seven
operations that i did every piece of
gear that i had to change the batteries
change the battery my knobs change the
battery my laser change the battery my
flashlight
changed every single bit i need a brand
new battery in every one of these pieces
of gear
well i was doing it because that's
that's when we talked about the big mesh
that's what we would think you know what
i gotta have this
100 we realized after a week
if everyone does that we're not going to
have any batteries left in another two
weeks
and so we all realize you know what
you're gonna have to wear use that
battery and keep track of how long
you're using it for you don't want it to
fail but
you're gonna get you know 12 or 15 or 25
uses out of this thing
but that's the kind of lessons that we
learned and that's the kind of comfort
level you got like okay if my nods fail
i'll stop i'll put a new battery in my
nods and we'll move on
so those are the kind of things that you
learn uh in that
steep learning curve that all of us our
whole generation went through that real
quick
and you only learned that with time in
the saddle like it takes
experience to understand like okay i can
use this lithium battery that probably
costs
nine dollars and i didn't turn it on the
whole time and i'm going to huck it
you know i think i can use it again i
mean but i mean everything changed the
tactics changed the gear changed the way
we trained
changed it was amazing what happened
post 9 11. all the stuff we thought was
going to be crazy effective because it
worked in vietnam
guess what doesn't work in the desert
let me ask you this
when you say that you only learn in the
saddle
when you were when you went through
training when i was when i was running
training
do you were able to convey a lot of that
information to those guys though
i tried i think i think you were and
maybe you couldn't give him every single
little tiny thing yeah but what i'm
saying is
there was no one to teach us that stuff
yes
in for me it was in 2003 there was no
one to say
hey you don't need to change your
battery on every operation you're gonna
need those batteries you need to make
them last
so we did get we did get some
fundamental knowledge back
from for sure from those early times and
then you still got to add that
experience though the people i mean like
you could
you could read a book and then go do it
for real and
you need the combination of the two to
have that confidence and then you can
impart it on somebody else
and you know history just like like you
said the vietnam guys like they were
just timed out
we didn't have access to that and i look
at the pre-911
training that we did
it was awesome but don't get me wrong i
loved it but man it doesn't work in
baghdad
yeah yeah and then we had a tactical
shift again in probably
2006 2007. you know it's just it's
that i think is what separates our
community
from a lot of other ones like we're
malleable like we have leadership that's
like listen this isn't working in real
time we need to create a solution for it
right now
and we're willing to do that we have
just a little bit more
control of the wheel yeah well part of
the reason is because we had no doctrine
yeah whereas the other service branches
many of them
have this beautiful really well
written doctrine on this is how you do
this type of operation and we didn't
have that
so guess what for us to say you know
what that didn't work yesterday we're
gonna change it today
they didn't have that capability they
were like hey this is the way we do it
yeah and we never really had this is the
way we do it i mean think about before
traded
i was at team five right so we would go
to alaska and do cold weather training
and the team three guys were off driving
dpv's i mean there wasn't even talking
in between the team so there was so much
skill set and of course i mean if you
were team three i wasn't telling you
[__]
i'd give you the wrong information
because we're competing with ourselves
but yeah that like you said no doctrine
and then finally we had you know the
trade at
you know east coast and west coast and
you know sharing information and coming
together and lessons learned and all
that stuff that
i think largely professionalized the
force from a paperwork perspective but
has impact on the battlefield as well
too
it's not sexy and it's not fun but it
keeps people alive
no there's no doubt about that the
amount of interoperability we would do
as the different training departments
was it was awesome
it was awesome and bouncing lessons
learned and the feedback loop with that
we got going was definitely
far superior to anything than like you
said when we had the teams going all
different
areas and not talking to each other i
mean i got issued over whites
at team five we they wouldn't issue us
tan bdu's
because we were a southwest asia platoon
and i'd look at the guys wearing the
chocolate chips my god i want to get a
pair of those
i'll trade you for this woodland cabin
[Laughter]
it's just a different world but i'm
actually
extremely grateful that i got to see
both sides of the coin because if you
never got to see that evolution
uh you're missing a huge piece of who we
are as a community
and also i believe it would be easier
that you would
that we could let it slip back in that
direction
if we don't like we said capture those
lessons and be able to pass them on